hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Freddy fazbear's
pizzeria simulator now we've got a
lovely place here but before we do
anything I'm gonna put safety strips on
that fruit punch guy and I'm gonna play
test Emma
surprise it's very good as you can all
right cool I'm gonna save my money I'm
gonna need them for the lawsuits that
are definitely coming with lefty up
there I shouldn't have left e there I'm
gonna have left e there the lawsuits are
which is a terrible thing to say but the
lawsuits are in fact hilarious
and to hire anyone that's okay alright
here we go here we go
place those bulbs baby handy bad get out
there you're doomed but get out there
[Music]
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die immediately
again
I expected to see you're not who I
expected to see either a baby going back
into it this game is I should I should
just [ __ ] use all my play-doh kit
shouldn't I okay I might do that
[Music]
ill-fated I suppose
[Music]
[Music]
poor baby bears poor baby bear
I'll just off sink the whole time no
don't give me those I don't feel like I
deserve those all right great I'm gonna
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go now go I'm
a-goin die again hi welcome to hell I
can't get away from you can I
no I don't like may not recognize me at
first but I assure you that still be oh
come on man man man man
[Music]
jeez
[Music]
excellent okay this is getting
ridiculous ly difficult hmm
lefty lefty you bastard lefty come on
Lusaka [ __ ] lefty I knew I couldn't
trust you I knew I couldn't trust you
lefty god dammit Wow this is the
jump-scare episode ah it was just the
episode of death God why why why is any
of this I don't know I do not know maybe
the risk is also on my part maybe that's
also part of the risk
alright maybe I gotta alleviate a little
bit of risk you know maybe I got tone it
down a bit because the risk seems to be
extremely high I'm extremely dying okay
let's let's sum this down to get all
lefty you know Lefty you got it you
gotta go to storage man you've gotta go
hey fruit punch man you're alright I
guess but uh this ball pit yeah you know
what some about this ball pit don't rub
me Ryan
put this one maybe I shouldn't have
bought the extremely cheap things
alright well that guy's okay I'm not
gonna get rid of him oh yeah there we go
risk nice eleven that's tolerable
I've done this to myself why have I done
this to myself I don't think it's gonna
help at all is it
[Music]
[Music]
you don't need to rub it in my face like
that okay so I'm missing a key mechanic
fundamental here obviously I'm missing a
key game mechanic fundamental cuz I'm
dying quicker and quicker light a madman
driving yes yes yes yes
ah markdown that doesn't seem good a pan
Stan you know pants Stan I don't think
anything's hiding in you but I don't I'm
not too into it just not into it by this
these fruity maze midnight motorists oh
look at these things yes markdown no no
who travel clay
oh you condition okay okay maybe I
should just never buy the horrible ones
I should probably just never all the
liability risk ones you know them
doesn't seem good you get to just get
out
take one alone and I motorcade you you
you get out Robo machine safety is my
number-one priority you oh no not you
know you know you know you there is no
risk cuz we got number one and we got a
good yes
the gang's all here we got big stir Ned
Fred mr. hippo and number one gage tiny
crate cram bloom yeah
and light light stolen light lamp Alden
all right I still don't think this is
gonna help me at all I still think I'm
boned very extremely boned finished
we're go now I'm still gonna die no you
didn't you didn't hear nothing actually
it was all actually a lot of nothing
surprisingly shockingly it was nothing
amazingly a whole lot of nothing
weirdly enough so much not so much
nothing you know
turns out turns out just a lot of just
like an oscillating fan myself
oh I mean I'm getting closer to the
truth but I still oh my god this is
difficult man why am i salvaging these
things why am i bothering why why do I
try
I always cut that I think what it is is
like the audio has a sphere of influence
that's what I'm seeing from that so the
audio needs to be if they're in that
right area they need to hear it to be
able to move it if I just put it in the
corner it's not gonna do any good I
gotta like lead them around away if that
is the case you know what I'm saying
that's what I gotta do it's so hard oh
my god
it's better than I've done in a while
[Music]
this is a lot of very cautious moves
stopping after everyone
oh no they're in both sides
[Music]
oh come on I heard your car no what I
don't know what to do
one more thing just one more you may not
recognize me at first but I assure you
that still me
[Music]
oh oh oh no no no no no no no was that
moving out
that's one less one missing
it's so stressful it's so stressful it's
so stressful but I'm learning with my
brain or you is an animatronic found in
the back alley oh you are unsure of its
origins it is your job to complete the
maintenance checklist before claiming it
as salvaged or if you choose to and
throw it back into the alley where you
found it and close it Ament please make
your choice now
[Music]
there's no panty there no pickle Peter
no pickle Piper Peter mr. Winkie Mon I'm
Oh going a little crazy okay I'll throw
you back don't forget Saturday you want
them all to be in one place nope I want
back I don't think I want that no one
turned away oh yeah oh oh yeah
lawsuits how did my last lawsuits go
probably not good okay alright wait hang
on oh this is coma girl you know what
I'm just gonna settle
i'ma settle that's all about and we won
hell yeah all right we'll settle this
one and now that'll be it that'll be in
because whoa Nellie welly welly Willie
okay so who's inside what's the new
sponsor Lally's lollies Lally's lollies
look at Lily got a lolly good time with
lollies lollies I'm up I wanna push
lefty back lefty you just the way you
move I just don't like it I don't like
it at all actually
so alright so anyway I'm all done for
this episode thank you everybody so much
for watching I'm getting better at this
but I can see how this is getting
impossibly hard well I'm getting better
at it so that's good so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think down the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]